hey guys I really want to thank you guys
for hanging out with at the amazing Las
Vegas Comic Con once again and it's cool
that you guys are here on Sunday I see
you know I mean do I see a lot of three
day three day badges a lot of VIPs a lot
of people are coming back more and more
well you know what it's really important
because I like if you're coming down
here for one day that is fantastic I
love you too the three day people I love
you too the two day people love you too
but see what I think is cool what we're
trying to do every year at amazing Las
Vegas Comic Con is adding more and more
programming and cool interactive
activities all throughout the entire
weekend because I think collecting
experiences are what comic conventions
are about it's not just getting a
signature it's not just you know digging
through you know back issue bins and
stuff like that it's collecting that
experience and we have a great
experience for you this afternoon and
this entire weekend as you guys know
legendary creator George Perez this is
his farewell tour everybody loves George
I don't know any one person that could
say anything bad about George Perez they
love his artwork they love his
personality they love what they give to
the fans those are all reasons that we
love George Perez and we are so
fortunate to share the last professional
West Coast appearance by mr. George
Perez so during this session we have a
great we have a great panel coming out
to you it's going to be presented by
Collider I want you guys all to you guys
have smartphones
take out your smartphones follow
Collider on your social media okay
because they are absolutely awesome
there they are
top destination for pop culture news
they have so much entertainment stuff a
lot of comic book content and they love
the stuff that we love and we're
celebrating pop culture all weekend long
I'm gonna introduce to the stage right
now
mr. koi jandreau he is from Collider and
he gets to hang out and talk Jorge Perez
with you guys all for the next hour
thanks so much
Khoi how we doing guys to say I'm a
comic fan doesn't do justice my
obsession and to say that the man I'm
about to bring up on stage is an icon
doesn't do him justice
the man shaped so much of our lives and
was an awesome dude while doing it and
that is a beautiful occasionally rare
thing but before I bring up George
there's someone who knows him incredibly
well and I want her to tell you some
some more of the greatness that is
George Perez Constance will you join me
[Applause]
hi everybody I'm not gonna put you in a
line yet I I know that I'm not who you
want to hear from so I'm just gonna take
a quick minute to give you a glimpse
into the gorge that I know who might not
necessarily be the gorge that you guys
all know now if you had created Starfire
and Nightwing and if you had drawn these
iconic characters none of which are on
the screen because I just got a horrible
look of me on a Jumbotron if you had
created these iconic characters and had
this storied career of Fame and
accolades you might think that that
might make you pretty proud right and
you'd have every right for that but if
you ask that man what makes him the most
proud and what gives him the most joy he
will tell you he will tell you that in
the past year he has raised money for
over 23 charities
not counting the hero initiative which
he gives generously to every year but
charities like Autism Speaks and st.
Jude and tear today Shriners Children's
Hospital he will tell you that he's
raised over a hundred thousand dollars
for these charities and he's done it
gladly and gratefully that his art and
his fandom can make that kind of an
impact and to me that's incredible that
out of all of these things out of all of
these accomplishments and out of all of
these
lives that he's touched and stories that
he's made and characters that he's drawn
what this man is most proud of is what
he's been able to give away and I don't
know many people that you can say that
about so I think we should all take a
minute think about that and then give a
giant round of applause to mr. George
Perez
welcome thank you thank you
your checks in the mail Constance I've
got to start off with one of my favorite
things about you is your love of your
wife and I start with non comics because
I love the shirts I love the the pure
passion I love that you know the amount
of weeks and I just I can't it's so
beautiful in specific and I want to how
did you meet your wife and and and we'll
start there okay
personal stuff that probably doesn't
matter to most of you but a friend I
should say ex friend unfortunately was
talking about this woman he met at a
party and he wanted to drive her to the
airport but he wanted me to meet her
worst mistake he ever made obviously and
that was March 1st 1980 and I met Carol
and we got along fine but didn't make
any assumptions that anything was gonna
go beyond that because of course I
assumed she was my friend's girlfriend
she disappears me of that on our first
date October 17th 1980 bad like that not
only wasn't she interested in him and
really and I didn't know this at the end
she said oh I fell in love with you and
at first sight and was hoping I would
finally get you know to a point that I
would you know at least ask to go out to
lunch with her and interesting it was my
friend when he said you know Carol
really wants to go out to lunch with her
and when you go out with her and find
out why she's not returning my calls so
he lastly was sending me out as a spy
and then I had I did have a previous
marriage and I was still a little
gun-shy and I told Carol I want to put
you know a platonic relationship so and
she was willing to honor that and I was
coming back from a convention and
Thanksgiving it was a I believe about it
been in Houston and usually I had to my
friend and pick me up at the airport
cause I didn't have a car and I said
just call Carol
and I said she would pick me up at the
airport and she said oh I would love to
I found someone can I bring him with me
and the way my heart sank I didn't
expect it to and I thought okay George
you really blew that one so you know I I
arrived at the airport in New York
Carroll finally showed up she was alone
and I asked if the person was parking
the car Oh didn't I make that clear I
found a dance partner deliberate
omission of words then that she says
because you said you want a platonic I'm
gonna call your bluff because if you
really wanted that I didn't want to
waste my time and we were intimate from
that day on and we were engaged January
15 1981 and on the 26th of this month
were celebrating 456 months of marriage
which for the mathematically challenged
is 38 years so incredible I always I had
to start there because it's just it's so
beautiful it's such a wonderful tale
that brings me into comics and she makes
all my shirts when you see me a
convention my wife makes all my shirts
so like I always will I cannot go to a
convention without a Carroll Flynn
original for fear that people are saying
oh my god something is something is
wrong with their marriage I can hear the
Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
galloping in now you know that's old
carols you know we have a responsibility
now i-i-i ache when I'm not with her she
actually gave up a dancing thing just
last week she was gonna spend an entire
three-day weekend and a dance function
that I was paying for the hotel and
everything else she wanted to leave
earlier she told everyone and told me I
miss my husband after 38 years lucky can
one man be and I got to draw comics soon
so that's the love of your life and the
other love of your life being comics how
did you fall in love with comics oh like
most people I mean I was at four or five
years old and picked up my first comic
it was an issue of Detective Comics with
Batman the silly periods I think
bat-mite might have been in it
and I just started doodling you know we
were a poor family so I would doodle on
paper bags grocery bags and just my
brother and I were always gonna we're
always too lenient at one point in my
life I thought Dave my brother Dave was
gonna be the artist in the family but he
left it for to pursue sports and other
things much much younger and when I was
in high school freshman year high school
a young classmate in his name's Tom
Shaka took me to my first comic
convention now I was addicted now there
was no that's my focus
I wanted to be a comic book artist and
nothing was gonna deter me so I just you
know kept drawing kept my get short
comic conventions eventually showed my
artwork to professionals I still have
the blisters on my back for that and
gladly I at the age of 19 while I was
working as a bank teller I thought after
high school
artists rich buckler who had seen my
artwork at a convention needed an
assistant he had a few so I mean I
didn't get to do really much drawing a
system
it was more like gofer work but I got to
go with him into the offices of Marvel
Comics I got to see all these people
solve bill Everett Frank Robbins all
these gigantic greats from the early
days of comics and people saw my work
and they knew I was hungry I was gonna
keep working drawing drawing drawing
that finally at the age of 20 I got to
do my first professional work which was
astonishing tales number 25 which
introduced rich buckler's Deathlok the
demolisher and there was a two-page gag
strip at the end of it and that's my
first professional credit where it shows
cartoon versions of Doug mentioned rich
buckler coming up with ideas too scarred
even throwing all that the discarded
pieces of paper into the trash can and
they leave the room and out of the trash
can from those discarded ideas comes
Deathlok and to show that I'm hey I was
still green rich buckler drew the Beth
loved figure he wouldn't trust me with
that one
but then you know I had the greatest
education possible I never had an art
lesson because uh because I was an honor
student when I applied to high school
New York School of Art and Design but my
mom really wanted me to have a Catholic
education so I went to a high highly
scholastic rated US Catholic school I
applied for their art program and I
wanted to relearn Spanish as my mother
tongue but because of an honor student
they gave me Latin instead of a Spanish
and they cancelled the art program the
year I came in and to make kumbhak this
come full circle a few years ago now
anyone has ever gone to any school any
college can identify with this I was
asked to come back to my high school for
George Perez day a you know you're
coming back to your school as a
conquering hero they were showing slide
shows all my artwork including on a
screen behind me at the auditorium from
another graduate of that high school who
donated the screen Martin Scorsese so my
stuff is being shown on a screen
provided by Martin Scorsese and they had
me lecture at the art classes that had
me giving encouragement to the student
body and believe me it took every bit of
self-control to they're told not to
utter the words I wanted to utter that
good luck with the art classes in the
classes that didn't give me when I was
in his high school but it was a
wonderful wonderful feeling so back that
things that full circle what inspires
you're very detailed but dense style
your panels are so lush and full of life
than with depth how did you develop that
style over time when you were first
starting I mean I was inspired by some
people who did some really lush detail
work like Barry windsor-smith red nails
was a revelation for me and other
artists in green jim Starlin when he was
also starting out with with Captain
Marvel and warlock and one of the things
I realized I mean I was carrying out
very quickly when I started you know so
I was through like
Drina have books a month but then I
really wanted to have a long-term like a
professional life as a comic artists I
had to start really knowing how to draw
I can't fake it and the amount of detail
I kept adding even when I was just
starting but because I was so in love
with the idea oh my god I'm actually
drawing comics I'm actually doing what I
wanted to do since I was a child and I'm
being paid for this and I always thought
even though the rates were horrible when
we started I'm lucky to be drawing
comics I want to show them I'm worth
what they're paying me so I add more and
add more and I and I enjoy team books
and at the time particularly the days
when they didn't offer you royalty so
you got the same page ready for drawing
a book that had a single lead character
and she worked to get a book I had a
dozen lead characters I wanted to draw
the dozen lead character so I became
valuable to the industry because I did
the books that no artists wanted to do
now of course every artist wants the
routine books that's where the money is
but I did it because of the sheer love
of it and because when you draw you tend
to be alone and a studio
I credit doing team books for keeping my
social skills intact because I didn't
treat the characters as just costumes
that I'd like puppets that move around I
try to imagine what they were like
inside those costumes which is why I try
to draw faces individual so that they
are individual characters I have to pay
attention to their body language to the
way they look at each other and some
basic changes on basics uniqueness in
their faces and that the way they
communicate with each other
kept it always in my mind how I need to
interact with society around me and they
were you know they were about writers
writing themselves and I'm sure art
characters writing themselves eventually
they seemed to be writing me too but I
just love doing team books
what's your creative process for
inventing characters you brought us so
many
characters like you have made them from
your own mind do you are you walking
around and one just pops up are you
sitting are you dude you have like a
process for well actually the bulk of
them were dumped with a writer so I
wasn't the sole person who came in I
mean uh like in the teen titans Marv had
a pretty good idea what he wanted he
described the characters he had no ideas
of what I was gonna do visually with
them like when I imagined Starfire
imagined a Red Sonja and outer space so
I used her and I used a specific model
in mind when I designed her body and my
first wife when I designed the face and
Raven I imagined her like a female
Phantom Stranger and trying to play that
up cyborg he was I had a greater
identification with cyber because he was
an inner-city youth I was born and
raised in the South Bronx in New York so
I had more like identify with him and I
used as a visual template for him young
Jim Brown the football player but
because of the fact that I didn't think
the Titans would last six issues there
was some shortcuts I took in defining
the characters that might have done
differently but in a way I'm glad I
didn't is like the sole self for Raven
straight out of the Doom Patrol negative
man
cyborg the Hat metallic mask
Deathlok through the inspiration for
that and again I mentioned Raven being
basically Red Sonja in outer space and
certain think I might have designed
differently if I actually thought these
characters were going to go anywhere how
did I could how could I imagine I could
retire
thanks for the Teen Titans and I thank
mark every single time I see him for
convincing me to do a book that I did
not think would last six issues and
Maher says neither did I but we did it
out of the fact that you just wanted to
do a fun book of character Marv had
ideas it gives really had a strong
passion for it and by the eighth
the day and the lives issue which
happened to be the book I was working on
when I had my first date with the woman
who was not my wife that's when I
realized these characters were now
special and Marv and I were now working
together to flesh out our babies I love
that you see using them to be social and
now they're 3d they're real like
Starfire's right here what's it like to
see that
now I must confess when I knew I was
coming in Las Vegas this is lovely young
woman of cosplay her name is Cheyenne
wise and I actually tell you have a
famine I a man and when I saw photos of
her as a character I was the one who
emailed her to let her know I'm coming
to Las Vegas that I hope that she would
be here so I can have my photograph
taken with her and the thing is I am so
in love with the idea that you fans
honor you don't know how much you honor
me and my profession when you a when
you're standing on line when you're
getting taking the troubling looking at
the designs trying to make them your own
making costumes doing charitable work as
the superheroes you know know how that
brings joy to my life I remember a few
years ago and asked cosplay was starting
to become popular
I had to come pretty much jaded from
going to conventions because I've been
doing it at that point you know for 30
years and I did this in Dragon Con which
is really the cosplay mecca of the world
and I told to them and I'm telling this
to Cheyenne and her friends as well with
everything that happened Jade have it
working for so many years the cosplayers
sparked my love for comics again you
guys by honoring what I did
suddenly made me feel you know I'm now
the youngest 65 year old you will ever
meet and that's because of all of you in
general and cosplayers in particular and
I thank you all for that
give yourselves a round of applause for
that
[Applause]
another of my favorite runs of all time
is your take on Wonder Woman how did
that come to be and what was it like
reinventing such an iconic character
yeah that was a surprise to a lot of
people because I walked into the office
at one point and this was after Christ
as an infinite earth I had one done my
run on Titans history that these
universe pretty much I was in a position
I could have asked for anything that I
either would have wanted to draw or
that's already existed or create
something I had pretty much carte
blanche at DC and then I was watching
and I knew that John Bernhard does I was
doing Man of Steel Frank Miller had had
just had his run on Dark Knight and was
getting ready to side with David
Mazzucchelli on Batman year one and then
I saw what they were having to do with
Wonder Woman and I was in the office and
there wasn't a single female employee
and a DC and this is a company that had
a woman for a publisher who were happy
with what what they had to do with
Wonder Woman because if they don't they
lose the rights to Wonder Woman because
they were still at a contract with the
Marston estate and I had an idea for
Wonder Woman story that I was going to
do when the one before crisis before the
the series that ended up ending Wonder
Woman's arc or current run and this was
before CGI and everything else and I
imagine I wondered haven't been inspired
by what Walt Simonson did with door
what if Wonder Woman was treated like a
Ray Harryhausen special effects fantasy
movie so I want to do a challenge at the
gods type story where she would meet
fighting skeletons hydras all these
mythological characters and then the
book had cancelled so when I came in
there you know I was just visiting
friends at the time and the editor
Janice Race was telling me what the
story was going to be like that they had
for the first issue that they had to
accept time was a premium at that point
and showed me the artwork and all I
thought for the female premiere
character in comics we were going to the
company was going to be eviscerated for
it because the the artist was more
suited to
in penthouse and it's not like I'm you
know like I have anything I have
anything against that but not that's not
what you want on Wonderman right now and
to give you an idea of certain things
like people praised me for creating
julia capitalist the female professor
who became her guide she wasn't into the
original story when Wonder Woman arrives
at man's world and it's in the first
issue as opposed to how I left that
until the third issue she ends up in an
alleyway some men try to rape her
immediately some guy comes in chases the
guys away it's a priest and she ends up
in a school and a house for wayward
women I said you're gonna be killed if
you released this as Wonder Woman and I
and I asked you have to I have some
ideas and I haven't worked a background
because I I wasn't planning on it
but if you give me a little time would
you like me to do Wonder Woman first
time I ever got kissed by an editor and
then Alaia publisher guy kissed my dick
Giordano - and they gave me the time I
needed to create a backstory and the
writer who on the book was very gallant
about him was willing to work with me
but by after the second issue with all
the changes that I was making along the
way he without any rancor without any
bitterness says you know this is really
becoming George's book I think it's
better that I just bow out I think he
also left the industry because he was
doing regular prose writing and Wonder
Woman became mine since I was starting
out as a writer Karen Berger the new
editor on was a little hesitant for me
to write the dialogue she didn't know
how well I could write and again they're
putting it she was banking a lot on
Wonder Woman so she hired Len ween to do
my dialogue but all the story concepts
were mine from that point on and then of
course by issue 17 I got a chance to
finally take over as the script or as
well but like Karen was my champion
because everyone saw Wonder Woman in the
all-boy Club there as a female Superman
and I said no she is a fantasy character
she's a character of myth there are
certain aspects of her I don't think
I've ever been it's been experimented
with or explored
and um the mythology was one thing again
inspired by Walt Simonson on Thor the
fact that she was a herald for peace I
had to I got rid of Steve Trevor as a
love interest because I was tired of
seeing a male Lois Lane you know I
thought Lois Lane was a dumb character
after a while and so Steve Trevor so I
tried to make him valid by making him an
older more older brother type making
Eric Andy a role model despite she was
head she was overweight and everything
else but she was a military officer very
very capable I wanted to show that
beauty is not pigeon-holed and creating
a women female characters there that fit
old age groups all ethnic backgrounds
all sizes to show that hero heroism does
not have a singular defined shape and
one of the things that Diana as I called
I never wrote her as one of my roles
wrote or as Diana the fact that she was
the only mainstream big league superhero
who practiced a religion and at that
point I'm and I still I'm pretty
agnostic but I got to develop a great
respect for those people who do follow a
religion and in the end it's the best
sense you know not when it separates
people when the unites people because of
Diana because I had to get into that
mind to study what makes her so
genuinely good and I think I became a
better man because of Diana and I am
brave for her and I'm grateful that when
I left the series it was you know Karen
Berger had to leave because of maternity
leave and the guys who are doing her you
know had their own ideas of Wonder Woman
some good some changes I would never
greed with but thanks to the movie that
came out and finding out from the fans
because I didn't I wasn't at the
premiere I didn't want to do the
premiere and people saying they captured
my Wonder Woman and Betty said but they
may change as well so did I when I got
on it and when I saw the movie said okay
there are a lot of major changes in
historical aspects of her but character
wise and I really didn't realize until
then how much I did contribute to wonder
ones personality in the modern times
until people pointed it out to me
because for me
so close to it and when I heard that
patty Jenkins the director based her
concept of wonder one on two people
William Marston and George Perez and
then when Phil Jimenez took a screen
shot and showed among the Thank You
credits my name separated from everyone
else's and said oh my gosh I never knew
that wonder what my wonder one would
last that long and for the number of
women who thanked me executive women who
thankful Wonder Woman I have to remind
them I didn't create the character but
despite the fact that my all my
wonderful financial success are
primarily due to the Teen Titans that
you know I can retire because the Titans
Wonder Woman that was my personal
triumph a character that everyone had
given up to but all I wanted to do was
say I could show that no character is so
bad or so helpless that you can't if you
put your love and dedication to it make
it work
Diana was that for me I am so incredibly
proud of my run on Wonder Woman yeah we
talked about the Wonder Woman film and
endgame was also this year and we're
living in a time of these comics that
we've loved since childhood are in a new
medium and they're actually translating
because the technology is there what's
it been like seeing stuff that was so
fantastical and only available in comics
translate to the masses and on their way
me and while I understand obviously
we're dealing with a different audience
and and like a period I've never seen
the Titans cartoon I've never seen the
Titans TV live-action TV series and I
know there are people who love it
fantastic but remember I'm the one who
designed them I've yet to see this is
why I'm absolutely in love with Cheyenne
anyway I actually do my characters the
way I designed them they all look so
different that I had a mental this
detachment for it marv
embraces them more because conceptually
Marv can and can identify with them
visually I can't they don't look like my
characters but when I see young children
who
grew up with the cartoon really that
next year that cartoon is 20 years old
the original Teen Titans cartoon series
and seeing that it led them into reading
the comics led them into the what well
then what are the grown up Titans like
and okay now I understand that I
respected but I tried to watch Titans go
to the movies just recently because it
was playing in the in the hotel room and
after 10 minutes I couldn't watch it I'm
sorry if it's just true but you know the
thing that flattered me the most was
when they were doing a copy of the
Marvel the flipping of the images that
they do for Marvel Studios and they were
doing that for the DC for the title is
that I recognize my statement that's our
fire let's move a star fire up there and
it is a wonderful feeling and I am glad
that now when I tell a person I'm a
comic book artist I may as well tell
them I'm a rock star it's wonderful
because I had Lian Luber driver taking
us from a Cirque de Soleil show here and
Joe Rubin scene and I were talking and
so the guy overheard he said you do
comics and we found out I created the
Titans he said oh my god I'm starstruck
I'd make sure my uber driver in crashes
and I actually had an uber driver back
in Florida take a selfie for mr. go from
his driver's seat so get a photo of me
is that my god and my wife had to come
to remind me honey
accept the fact you're a celebrity as
for me I'm just a starstruck fan who
can't be more people for the life I have
thanks to comics now the medium of
comics for me is is the best combination
of literature and art it's truly
supersedes all others for me what is
your favorite thing about the actual
medium is it the bringing people
together it's the stories and the scope
is the infinite budget and the panel's
are like what makes you love comics for
me love Thomas it's like it for me it
was a fantasy that got me out of the
South Bronx I've been a very violent
neighborhood it kept me out of being in
gangs and everything else but it also
made me the outsider and one of the
things about creating stories with these
characters they're all outsiders and
despite anything you had a
yet a man whose entire planet was
destroyed who came to this planet and
with the power to become man's Conqueror
he became man's servant he was a hero
and the idea of heroism and doing good
for the sake of being good enchanted me
I wanted to be part of that I want to
create stories about heroism that heroes
shouldn't be defined by being the last
man standing in a fight because they
took the moral high ground they won
because they were good
I remember one thing I used to bother me
as I was growing up and it's the way to
describe Superman I took it when
Batman's darker nature was being brought
back into the comics Superman's an
overgrown Boy Scout suddenly one that
being a boy's got become a derogative
operative comment you know they're out
to do good deeds and as the idealism of
a Boy Scout said when is that becoming
an insult how jaded are we becoming as a
society when if a person is doing good
just for the sake of being good we
wonder what is he really after and I
think we need more heroes we need more
people who aren't don't need to be
rewarded for being good but being good
as they say for goodness sake I could
talk to George for four hours but with
we've got about ten minutes left I want
to let you guys ask some questions
because it's George Perez you guys and I
I don't want to be that selfish so I'm
gonna I'm gonna get this cube out it's a
microphone
maybe so I'm gonna toss this around and
we'll get to some questions a little man
in Super Mario shirt and talk loud I'm
going to death so what is your favorite
person you ever created Oh see that's a
question I get last lot and I'll tell
you you're asking me to choose them on
my children right that's why I do team
books so I can do all the characters
instead of having to concentrate on one
because anyone who has a family and has
more than one child if they're asked
who's your favorite child one day this
one might be the other day the other one
might be
it's like it's the same with me I mean I
love everybody which is why when I'm
asked when I was asked to do the
Avengers when I was asked to do
jla/avengers when I was asked to do
crisis on Infinite Earths I was asked
what characters that you want to draw
how many characters do you have I wanted
to draw everybody that's why I got into
comics did you have a question too
little man how was your work on infinity
in Infinity Gauntlet
what do you mean how how was it well the
thing is I just enjoyed drawing all the
characters and when I found out now I
felt a little bad at first drawing
Infinity Gauntlet I thought he should
have gone to Ron Lim from the very
beginning and when I got a chance to
draw all these Kip Marvel character I
had been joined from Marvel so long I
was working at DC I was like yes just
told him sterling I want a lot of
characters in there but Jim already had
to script ready and so I was drawing it
but I was also drawing a series from DC
Comics well were the gods and I I
couldn't handle it all but when I when
they originally asked me when I was
falling really far behind on issue 4 is
that they have Ron Lim finished issue 4
and I could jump on to issue 5 but I
said I said I don't know if I can ever
get back on time and really give it to
Ron let Ron finish it he should have
started it from the beginning he did the
Infinity Gauntlet before that he came he
and Ron
Jim ston have already working on
Donald's and Silver Surfer he should
have gotten it but I didn't want the
fans thinking that I left the book cause
I was angry or anything else so I said
let me ink Ron's covers for the book so
they know that I'm so participating but
I can it was just I had too much work to
do and that's why I couldn't do it all
but while I was doing it I want to make
sure if I'm coming back to Marvel I want
to make sure this is the guy you've been
missing so I tore it up on Infinity
Gauntlet you know next question hands
there we go yeah sure just say thank you
for everything my pleasure
yep
when you were growing sorry when you're
growing up in the neighborhood read
comics what was the one character more
than all all the others they inspired
you I didn't I don't think was a one
single character but at first there was
not the artist who inspired me it was
the arc like I can sense the different
styles even then even though many comics
didn't have credits Curt Swan was my
first influence Jack Kirby came in and
then the the real game changer Neal
Adams and then there were others like
Barry windsor-smith he'll change on view
similar I'm Lee summers Avengers I
worshiped and then you had Neal Adams
doing x-men you know that oh my god all
these people that are coming out there
and again I can see little bits of them
and all my work and then trying to
filter them to my own sucker I don't
want to I
there was only one Neal Adams I didn't
want to be another copy of Neal Adams
I'd be a copy of a of Curt Swan or Jack
Kirby or anyone else I said I had to
find a way of taking all that I learn
and filtering it to my style as weak as
it might have been and try to create an
identity of my own but more than any one
single character
it was the creator's who really inspired
me back or is it toss it it's a nerf we
love I'm gonna miss you okay safety
second thank you because you made the
independent Wonder Woman that we all
like it's not dependable you know her
and she tightens it was all good to be
different and be still good you know
we're all we're good for all in
differences but my question for you is
now that you're retiring what are you
gonna do well I'm married and my wife is
a ballroom dancer she's also a belly
dancer and I really want to just throw
their support some of her endeavors
she's been there to support mine and I
sort of tend to be drawing I mean for
those of you young cover your ears
our friends in the fetish industry and I
do fetish videos for them so I do a lot
of writing editing and special effects I
do super heroines cat fighting and
everything else and DT wrestling calm
and I'm also one of the show's I still
do regularly I'll be doing it for the my
11th straight years fetish con in st.
Petersburg Florida where I host an event
with all these girls dressed up as super
heroines and getting tied up on stage
what kind of life do I live oh god you
don't know I love it so that's what the
end that's one thing I'll be doing I did
do one more new page for Marvel for that
Marvel 1000 that had the 80 pages there
is a new one page story there by me a
writer who was writing the white tiger
character cuz I wanted to do one last
page with the white tiger because he was
the first character I got to draw on a
regular basis at Marvel Comics if it's
going to the history of Marvel Comics
that'll be part of my history too and I
do a crossword puzzle I like to travel
and either and I'm actually doing a
fetish comic book using the same
characters I using the fetish videos
with all these beautiful young women for
jazz at this senior citizen who's making
them heroes and I can spend as much time
as I need per page there are no
deadlines um because now it takes me two
weeks minimum to do one page because of
my eyesight I use Photoshop in order to
blow up those images and draw you know
put all the extra details and I cannot
do by hand anymore but of course I can't
maintain a monthly deadline doing that
was just what I'm retiring and there are
a couple and I did say this in my
retirement letter if somebody comes up
with something interesting and they give
me time who knows you may see me again
[Applause]
so like it said you've been in the
industry so long has there ever been a
period where you've been handed
something to draw and you just read it
like wait what did you want me to do
haha that's funny because one of the
people I say that about is usually me
one other thing I tell all the writers
because uh cuz I was talking to a writer
artist at one point I don't know what
how he thinks when he's creating a story
and he said well I will never write as
the writer I will not write something
that the artist won't draw and I thought
I heard I said you know that's the most
stagnating thing I've ever heard to me
if I get a stripped from a writer and
I'm cursing their names I'm reading it I
know I will be a better artist when I
finish it because he's challenging me
he's pushing the envelope he's tearing
the envelope sometimes but I will be a
better artist cuz I'm facing the
challenge and doing my best on it I did
that with myself for those who remember
the first issue of the Baxter Titans
series that I drew and I created this
wall of twisted Souls as trigons
in trigons world all these gnarled
bodies that created bridges Marv Wolfman
original partly described bridge that
gnarled bodies was something I wanted to
do because if challenge me more and of
course then I was cursing my name
because I drew this it said oh my god
now I got to draw this four more pages
because it's not just one image it's a
it's a scene so I had to keep drawing it
and drawing it and drawing it cursing my
name every single second I drew it and
then thanking myself when I blew it up
so like uh but but the thing is I'd like
it my second Avengers story I ever drew
back in the night when I started my
career oh my god I'm drawing the
Avengers what did Steve Englehart do in
the very second issue he threw them into
the Old West I never drew a horse in my
life but I had to learn how to get books
on it it made me a better artist faster
because they didn't pray to my
weaknesses they tried to increase my
strength
yeah can you talk a little bit more
about why you didn't think New Teen
Titans would succeed and kind of how you
felt when you found out it was gonna be
it was such a breakout hit for DC at the
time
well that mean the history of T's what
made me stick it wasn't gonna succeed
because I mean the Titans had their
legendary run back in the nineteen
sixties you know with Nick Carter doing
the bulk of it and then it floundered
then they try to create a new version
which basically was the Justice Little
League because they were just junior
versions of already existing adult
characters and jenette Kahn even though
it did okay himself the publisher hated
it so like she was gonna add when it was
gone so in Marv Wolfman and Len Wein
came in and said they had an idea for do
a New Teen Titans book Jeannette was not
all that gung-ho the thing that sold it
to her and was willing she was willing
to give it a chance was when they said
we've got George Perez to draw it but
she was aware of the work I was doing at
Marvel and the only reason I did it was
as a favor to Marv you say I'll do the
scene times only if you get me a chance
to draw the Justice League that was the
book I wanted to draw and of course at
that point for first Mike sakowski and
then dick Dylan we're having incredibly
long runs on the book as a particular
Scott to have a vacation sometime just
let me do one issue and then out to the
Teen Titans and as I started to teen
times and I could feel kind of guilty
about it dick Dylan had a heart attack
and died so I ended up having a chance
to now do the Justice League but I
promised the Titans and it after the
first issue particularly DC did the
unimaginable by offering a free 16 page
comic inside another comic in DC Comics
presents number 26 to introduce the
Titans it was never done before you can
you know 16 more pages of art without
any increase in the price I think that I
think they have a little more faith in
this or they're putting a lot of trust
in me and when it the sales figures came
in after the third issue
this book is doing well and then and
Marvin I was being given bonuses and the
like and everything else and I was
grabbing royalties started coming in
because it's a Marvel I was trying to
feel guilty for getting bonuses because
this book sold and all these other
artists were working so hard it's not
their fault that their books weren't
selling nothing at DC was selling except
the Teen Titans so and DC and its credit
when they introduced a royalty system
and because the way was structured
originally only the Titans was earning
royalties so they lowered the break-even
point for books to sell so the other
books can start earning royalties too
that was the incredibly brave thing they
did all around thanks the Teen Titans
yeah alright one last question this
gentleman right here you mentioned that
people like Kirby were some of the ones
that inspired you how does it feel
knowing that that for people today
you're Jack Kirby you're the person that
inspires them and what kind of advice
would you give someone trying to follow
in your footsteps
you know I'm incredibly flattered and
inspired I think it was when I've worked
when I asked you to come work across
chamber I said because we want you to be
the elder statesman of the company and I
realized that
Stanley was 13 years younger than I am
now when I met him and he was an icon to
me other artists I mean I'm a 65 of real
you know I am older than most of these
other artists I met in the industry who
inspired me and the fact that people are
young artists who are working here at
the either who are working
professionally or doing their own books
self-publishing
and they were inspired by me Hellyeah
thought that makes me feel incredible it
makes you feel a particular pinpointing
certain specifics about this what I've
done for the industry that I just wanted
to be part of the crowd part of the
person of the gang who drew comics to
realize and again I think it's because
of my sheer love for it I made a
difference that I was not just another
replaceable artist in the industry that
a George Perez comic meant something to
people because it was a George Perez
comic and I am flattered I am flattered
by this attention
I never imagined how many people would
be responding with such kindness
melancholy as well when I announced my
retirement and everyone wished me well
everyone was for me good health and
thanking me for the years I have been
there and I'm thank you for letting this
little boy of from five years old get to
live his dream and to share it with so
many people and knowing that they're
gonna be a lot of five-year-old 50 year
olds hundred years old we're gonna look
at my work and said he made a difference
and thank you for that
is a beautiful spot to land everyone
give it up for Jorge Perez
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]